a lot of our viewers asked about pitch
meetings and how to acquire one how does
someone get a pitch meeting at your
company well DRG is a bit different
where you know we're mostly co-producing
with major networks or major production
companies so there's already kind of an
established relationship there and I
guess that's sort of the key point in
terms of how do you begin that process
how does one open the door to get that
kind of open communication with an
acquisitions team or development team so
not just the drg but any company you
kinda have to understand what that
company wants what they work with what
they like to you know what was on rows
of content they'd like to work with
whatwhat getting a sense of us who their
kind of key clients are you know for
instance at DRG we work a great deal
with you know Netflix who work a great
deal with RLJ acorn where you know
there's specific networks that we have
great relationships with when I was at
Mar Vista with great relationships with
lifetime Disney Nickelodeon so we would
at marvista we were producing content
that was kind of catered towards those
audiences I on networks and a few others
and at drg we have a different set of
companies that we work closely with that
we just have a library of media that
works well with those so our
acquisitions team has a different
mandate than what the acquisitions team
at Deere that marvista had and so if
you're going to go into a company and
attempt to build that kind of you know
initial let's see if some of my ideas
are going to work well and we can get
something going you have to first
understand what that company does what
it is they like to work with what media
they're actually in need of and then the
best way to get a pitch meeting is to
poised you're kind of introduction as a
way of being able to serve their needs
to help them accomplish their content
goals so like you know if they're
looking for women in parallel films
they're looking for you know action
zones you going into those companies
pitching those two scripts are going to
be great if you if you go in pitching
stuff it has nothing to do with their
core values of the company in terms of
what they are identified with in the
marketplace you're not going to get a
warm reception it would probably mean
it's just they're looking for ways to
satisfy finding the content that they
need so if you can position yourself
where you're kind of answering to that
need the best way to get it I know with
marvista we talked about the goldmine
genre and it was women in peril or
between comedies or things like that
yeah things that were maybe lighter it
sounds like with DRG maybe that some of
the darker things like the Norwegian are
is more acceptable so it really depends
again what you're saying on finding out
what what they represent and going to
that so maybe a tween comedy wouldn't
work for DRG a tween comedy wouldn't
work at all two years ago when I was at
Mar Vista you know I would have jumped
up and down if you gave me an
opportunities it's because the mandate
of the company is different there's just
a different need and in addition to dark
Nordic Noirs and you know other deep
serious scripted content we also have a
great deal of one-off factual films you
know this has got that marvista that
would never work but we have a massive
library of like one-hour documentary
type programs that do amazing in the
digital space we have a great collection
of game show formats we have you know a
great collection of like we call
lifestyle programming where it's like
cooking and you know DIY type stuff you
know it's a totally different library
every company has a completely different
package that they're selling to the
marketplace distribution companies to be
successful they need to be kind of brand
that is one thing or another and because
you know because they're kind of branded
that way it attracts certain types of
buyers from international marketplace
there's only so many channels in the
world there's only so many media buyers
in the world
and they all have limited budgets so you
have to kind of distribution companies
that position themselves to be different
in the marketplace and so they develop
and a streamlined system of this content
works really well because we're able to
transact on it easily let's get more of
that that's kind of how they think so to
go in that's just a pitch meeting but if
you want to showcase your script if you
want to be a producer and you know
produce content and have it you know get
hired by a company to produce content
for them you have to be able to position
yourself to that company to say I
already do stuff like that therefore I
can help you out you know what I mean
right so almost like back engineer where
a filmmaker knows that their film fits
into this category and then see who has
distribution that's similar to their
film exactly but then can they just call
up you said that that's already
established relationships I'm just
curious it's interesting if I was a
filmmaker and had a let's say a thriller
that I wanted to have you know looked at
it sounds like that's not the channel
that's not the proper way to go about it
in terms of me reverse engineering is
exactly the way to do it it's just that
you have if you already have a script if
you already have a film or if you just
have an idea like a treatment or
anything along those lines that you're
trying to get out into the marketplace
first off if you're only at a treatment
stage I would try to package it or you
know get some other elements in there
but but going to a distributor that is
in alignment with whatever project
you're trying to pitch that's how you
begin that introduction of this is how
we can start that process of you know
being regular in regular conversation
about this topic and potentially future
once it's walking in the door by reverse
engineering it in the sense of I know
this company works in these two genres
of three genres my project fits that
very very well focusing on the companies
that fit that and then talking them
basically saying look I know you
produced this stuff or I know you
develop or co-produced this kind of
material I have something very much in
alignment with it maybe we can talk
about it and if it's at an early stage
like a treatment or you know just
initial you know rough draft screenplay
type thing going to them early and kind
of saying I want to cater this for you
give me your advice or your feedback or
even better if you're a producer hey I
want to produce this you know woman in
peril thriller I want to produce this
tween comedy
going to a company that works in that
and saying I'm going to produce it I'm
going to fund it I'm going to figure out
how to get the money for it what I want
from you is a clear understanding of
what works what's going to make it a
great film in the marketplace for a
great product in the marketplace and if
you know in exchange for that I'd love
for you to be have a first look at
acquiring it later you know that way or
even trying to sign a deal where they
get the opportunity to have it
regardless and then they're now they
have something at the back end to have a
filmmaker who's going to produce the
whole thing and they get to coach and
create the exact movie they want and
they're guaranteed to have it at the end
of the day you know like that's kind of
how you do it you create opportunities
for the production companies or for
distribution companies that make their
job easier and if someone just calling
up and finding the right contact I mean
like insurance is sort of a delicate
process into getting that introduction
because the filmmaker doesn't to come
off too pushy doesn't want to send an
email that's just too much information
what's what's the proper way to kind of
just ease in just a little bit nothing
but not you know with a lot of
expectation not with too much pressure
on the other person
I find LinkedIn is a great source
because everyone in the professional
world is on there and you look for terms
like acquisitions anyone in the
acquisitions Department of a
distribution company or executive
producers who work for production
companies those are sort of the
individuals tasked with making things
happen bringing stuff in and I wouldn't
if you're going to be jumping out to
people blindly do they get a lot of
people hounding them all the time so
that's kind of why I go back to you
can't look at it as what can you do for
me and how can you help me make my movie
you have to say I understand your
company is looking for material like
this and I would like to help you with
your search if you if you back engineer
it
you are help you're making their job
easier you're helping them achieve a
goal it's going to help them
professionally and now all of a sudden
they're going to be a lot more receptive
to listening to you and you position
yourself differently than all the other
noise that's out there it's kind of how
you do it and from that you know don't
make the mistake of going after the top
dog at every company you know like don't
go after the CEO or the head of this or
the executive VP of that because they
are bombarded with work all the time and
that's just within the company that's
not you know you know random people
reaching out so go for juniors go for
middle managers go for people and
companies who are hungry who have more
open time and who are looking for those
opportunities to bring stuff in because
it helps them also professionally
achieve that next level in the company
you